wie sieht meine fresse auf meine fresse
sieht fantastisch aus
er ist vorteile sind ich weiß gibt es so
eine gute idee ist für ihn vor dem video
zu trinken aber sind wir mal ehrlich ihr
seid hier mit der kleine hoffnung dass
diese adventskalender dieses jahr auch
mal wieder so richtig rein schals und
ich weiß ich weiß
ich möchte es auch eine andere seite von
mir möchte dass der beauty
adventskalender von bmw gut ist hier ist
das gute stück willkommen zum 2020er
unboxing form gmp adventskalender sind
alle heiß und ich muss auf jeden fall
ein retro perspektive sagen das ging
ganz schön gut rum
ich glaube manche leute bei gmp sind
jetzt nicht mehr so gut auf mich zu
sprechen so war das wieder losgeht ich
wurde nicht bezahlt ich habe ihn mir
selber gekauft nichts hier ist eine
bezahlte kooperation werbung sponsoring
oder irgendwas in dieser art nur mal
kurz vorweg deine atem haben und alle
vorher zu beruhigen
diesen adventskalender überhaupt
auspacke noch an dieser geschichte habe
ich bei ihm gesagt dass ich den
newsletter erhalten möchte wer schickt
mir jeden tag zwei e-mails seitlich
diesen adventskalender bestellt gm habe
versucht mich schon auch zu melden aber
dann muss man sich irgendwie einloggen
und dann habe ich meine login-daten
schon wieder vergessen und dann also
dieser adventskalender kostet 19 euro 99
ist der erstmals können
ein guter preis ich bin aber ein
bisschen verwirrt weil ich mich frage
warum ein juti adventskalender also wenn
ich jetzt zum beispiel der chef von emp
wäre dann würde ich doch niemals sagen
mensch so ein beauty adventskalender den
wird uns jeder aus der hand reißen das
passt nicht so ganz zusammen
deswegen glaube ich werde ich mich
gleich einfach nur aufregend weil
wahrscheinlich keiner bei mp wieder eine
ahnung hatte und einfach irgendein
bullshit reingepackt haben
wir sind jetzt in wir sind jetzt wieder
machen kalender spirit wir fangen an mit
türchen simon lee chang palette die ich
mit meinen fingern ideen handeln
reflektieren
die community ist schwierig eine
lidschatten palette sehr dezente rosa
töne die ich jetzt zum beispiel meiner
mutter zuordnen würde also die
verpackung sieht halt super schlicht aus
würde ich keine kleider zu den
inhaltsstoffen der produkte nicht sagen
aber es is made in china
wenn ich mit make-up auskennt schreibt
mal ob das normal ist das make-up somit
in china ist aber jetzt dass made in
china
hier steht auf deutsch hergestellt in vr
china volksrepublik wahrscheinlich die
firma die das vertreibt also glaube ich
dass die das vertreibt brie conti gmbh
was macht die bre conti gmbh wenn man
auf die konti de geht gibt es zu einer
website die nur die produkte abgebildet
haben und china bric conti aber du
kannst auch etwas drauf klicken also
der geschäftsführer ist joachim bitter
und michaela weg nach wenn ich die
geschäftsführer von groupon.de joachim
bitter und michaela wegen eingeben dann
komme ich schon zwei cosmetics also sie
besitzen nicht nur bei conti sondern
auch zwei cosmetics ich habe diese
vermutung dass michael wegner und
joachim bitter einfach aus china so
fertige produzierte sachen kaufen hier
haben sie es einfach noch mal anders
verpackt das schreiben sie zwei
cosmetics rauchen das ist halt einfach
direkt das haben da haben wir einfach zu
malen nicht drauf gemacht damit sie das
über np verkaufen können also dass er
jetzt einfach den scheiße vielleicht
gibt es ja einen instagram account
es ist die gleiche ihre künste zeigen
sie gleich bei rossmann kann man den
gleichen adventskalender allerdings mit
einer ganz bisschen anderen verpackung
aber den gleichen produkten vom break
even 12 eur 99 haufen mensch dmp warum
paktieren noch sieben euro drauf wenn es
den aufbau 12 99 geben könnte es sein
dass sie wieder schrott verteilen wollen
[Musik]
wir schauen jetzt erstmal zwei sind wir
sind viel aber jetzt gucken mal dass die
produkte zu können ich kann mich ein
bisschen kommt mein gesichtern ein
bisschen kenne ich nicht mit make-up aus
deswegen kann ich euch jetzt meine
ehrliche fundierte meinung dazu sagen so
sehen sich als dann gehe ich da mal rein
in einer farbe so das hab ich jetzt am
finger teilweise drauf jede farbe sie
tatsächlich gleich aus obwohl diese
müssen ist eine sehr schlimme rhi hand
von china stoppt sieben euro teurer als
rossmann beziehen manche schnell durch
natürlich nur weil mein gott der pre
konnte nicht mal wenn man so versucht
herausfinden
lipstick scandal
das ist ein fuß ich glaube man sieht ja
nicht meine farbe das heißt lipstick
ich bin noch die lücken machen aber ich
muss für euch mal das experiment ganz
ehrlich vielleicht überzeugt mich auch
wer weiß
[Musik]
ein schöner nebeneffekt wir auf jeden
fall wenn ich plötzlich so richtig auf
unser leben dürfen haben qualität für
sie ein bisschen komisch gerade an dass
sie noch ein bisschen drauf mal gucken
so türchen nummer drei so ein kleiner
pinsel ist drin ich schätze mal und hat
dieses classic teilnahme sind zornig ich
weiß nicht was für 12 99 hätte kriegen
können diese büste wird wieso wir
brauchen gerade nicht darüber reden ob
das eine gute qualität darüber ob das
den bizarren gut auftragen wird weil
wird es nicht aber wir lassen uns mal
weiter überraschen der lippenstift mit
mir auf jeden fall bis jetzt endlich weg
die braukessel in der farbe pinsel als
soll es ja auch so ein festival sap sein
weil du würdest ja niemals sein normales
make up zum festival mitnehmen weil es
könnte ja verloren gehen und so eine 50
euro lidschatten palette witz nicht
verlieren ab die conti das kannst du die
tonne treten
ich frage mich gerade wer hat so rothe
augenbrauen meiner hand probieren
meine augenbrauen heulen wenn ich da
jetzt die farbe drauf machen kommt hier
meine klasse kant also wow ich würde
sagen okay so als anfänger einsteiger
aber die farbe ist halt das ist halt das
problem bei solchen sachen 5
der machen ein türchen nummer fünf
also das ist der lipgloss in der farbe
lipgloss sehr viele dieser partikel sehr
viele ja und daher machen wir es mal
nicht so gut
der mensch ist der break on die lip
gloss etwa ein geheimtipp
ich mein man sieht das ist jetzt kein
high end produktes was ich würde so
rausgehen können tierchen selbst fleisch
in der farbe blau
wollen wir doch gleich mal gucken ich
meine ich habe schon ein bisschen blass
strafbar
das hat den gleichen ton wie der
lippenstift damit muss ich vorsichtig
sein
ich habe ein bisschen übertrieben ich
sehe es auch so bleibt ist halt nur so
ultra low aber das ding ist bei der
ganzen beauty community auf instagram
und youtube dürfen wir halt auch nicht
vergessen es gibt immer noch leute die
sich kein fan die 40 euro blush kostete
so viel ich weiß es nicht leisten können
man macht jetzt auch blatter von
nasenrücken ich kriege von allen
produkten diesem weit von dem
schminkkasten die man so als kind
bekommen hat also der börse in nikolaus
nummer 7
und in der 7 den passenden pinsel als er
es schrott acht farben türkis und blau
ne das ist halt so dass kidman stärkste
es rot ist eine enttäuschung das rosa
war sie mit ganz viel fallout 1 lebt in
der farbe le pens batterie -krimi ja
nicht katastrophe wenn deine erwartungen
schon so niedrig ist dass du dich über
nicht katastrophe frau ist aber erwartet
und so nummer 10 ist und mascara ich
muss ein face damit machen ich sehe
schon ein
na ja so als kleine notfall mascara in
der handtasche es bestimmt schon gut
warum man auch immer eine notfall
mascara bräuchte denkt euch selber aus
mir fällt gerade einfachen mann eine
nutzer mascara bräuchte glas cream jetzt
wirklich das ist kinder make up das ist
kinderschminken make up und es ist aber
das ist wirklich so eine person pflege
das ist gar nicht big meal kommentiert
es gibt einfach nur so ein rosa amazon
ist ein großes kirche was habe ich ganze
gebraucht ein spiel das ist es noch
alles setzt noch alles finde ich
irgendwie so ein spiegel denn da packe
ich gerne meine hand also alles losgeht
ambri konnte eigentlich an die
volksrepublik china den sie an das
make-up hergestellt ist das
holografische was ist das ist das erste
produkt was mit einem taser band
verschlossen wurde
das ist eine interessante farbe deshalb
so ein rosa und dann aber auch
gleichzeitig grünlicher schimmer hat
dachte gerade os kann man als pflege
benutzen aber wie gesund ist in alles
dicker die wirklich nicht mehr im trend
sind aber irgendwer wird sich schon
drauf machen leute
ich wusste nicht dass ich es im leben
braucht aber ich brauche jetzt habe ich
die welt ja eigentlich auch clement aber
irgendwer mit sich schon drauf machen
okay für zu 15 dass ich bis jetzt gut
finde ist dass nicht so viele produkte
sich wiederholen und da kommt der zweite
lipgloss
da bin ich ehrlich mit euch gemeinsam
mit klaus bezahlt man sonst 89 euro der
ist ja nicht mal ein euro wert aber ich
muss sagen an der kamera sind die lippen
produkte echtzeit aus oder es kann auch
sein dass ich jetzt einfach nicht
richtig erkennen und ist total furchtbar
aus sieht aber für mich fühlen sich
gerade recht gut an und sie haben alle
kein paar firmen oder so das finde ich
gut so alle produkte bis jetzt waren
geruchs preisen gutes zeichen bezeichnet
ziel nummer 16
oh oh da wo dann uns gedacht firma der
anspitzer für die lippen und augenbrauen
produkte sehr gut 17
[Applaus]
silvester kann kommen wenn das mal nicht
robbins pakets ist bei gts ist
gepresstes glitzern mit aber auch
sonnencreme
das ist halt behält das ist gut zu
dosieren man hat nicht gleich so über
als zu viel glitzer aber man kann hier
so ein glitzer finch machen
die conti lasst uns mesiano bands
kalender machen und wir verkaufen den
für 30 euro ich mache auch halbe-halbe
mit euch komplett überzeugt von diesem
produkt wenn sie wieder ihr sehen könnt
hensel naja der kajalstift sehr darf
nicht fehlen
der ist so spiel zu mir ins auge zu
reiben küche nummer 19
na klar eine roter lippenstift
es ist jetzt nicht so pigment in your
face aber es ist halt so was cremig ist
und es färbt auf jeden fall die lippen
ist wozu der gut wäre dann auf den
koreanischen style steht wenn sich ein
bisschen auf dem finger lässt sich das
hier ist natürlich viel zu schleppen
produkt drauf und dürfte sich das so ein
bisschen von innen nach außen dann hat
man so einen sehr natürlichen rosen in
ton ist er seine lippen creme so
eingefärbte aber so petra soll man da
sagen außer mach dir mal die hand 20
na klar eine nagelfeile funktioniert
einwandfrei türchen 21h wieder eine
lippen creme diesmal in so nem tun haben
wir den ton an wir haben sowas helles
antoniazzi
22 ein rosa blush 23 doch mal eine
lidschatten palette in grau und weiß und
schwarztönen ich denke aber nicht so
hoch kommentiert dass man da jetzt
crassus machen kann aber jetzt kommen
wir tatsächlich schon zum letzten
türchen 24 also ich hoffe ihr wisst dann
etwas isst ich demonstriere dass es
jetzt quasi mein fuß und dann machst du
dann sind seine zähne auseinander
gestalten kannst du sind lackieren da
wir aber kein nagellack in dieser
geschichte haben ist das halt auch ein
bisschen das ist ehrlich das ist ein
beschissenes 24 türchen das ist macht er
gar keinen sinn
es könnte auch eine süße krone sein und
ich muss sagen der letzte
adventskalender den wir ausgepackt haben
der sich euro gekostet hat und wo er
wirklich nur schrott drin war
war ja aber ein original emp mit erp
produkten in diesem fall haben sich bei
conti und emp zusammengepackt und ihre p
hat gesagt ihr könnt ihr euren
adventskalender den ja auch hier bei
rossmann für 12 99 verkauft könnt ihr
einfach die verpackung ändern und emp
draufschreiben und den dann fühlen also
also wir kaufen ihn für den gleichen
preis wie also wir packen aber 1999
hilfe in den für mehr verkaufen
und deswegen ist es halt bullshit weil
19 99 ist es einfach nicht wert da hat
sich emp gedacht wir müssen mal wieder
ein bisschen kohle machen und natürlich
emp seine firma versteht mich nicht
falsch eine firma sollte geld verdienen
und ganz ehrlich die 20 euro kann ich
jetzt verschmerzen und ich sage okay
jetzt für das testvideo aber 25 euro ein
bisschen mehr
und das ist auch in ordnung so und jetzt
bin ich wieder verwirrt bei ich frage
mich für wen ist dieser adventskalender
weil wenn ich jetzt eine nicht oder
das navi so um die zehn jahre zwölf wann
fängt man mit make up um zu spielen
ich glaube ich habe mir zehn schon
angefangen auf jeden fall dann ist es ja
ganz süßer sich die lippenstifte das
finde ich ja niedlich aber dann ist ja
die verpackung zum beispiel schon mal
blöd sein der bei rossmann für 12 99 war
so orange so süß weihnachtlich und das
ist dann frage ich mich wer ist ein
ehepaar kunde wen haben sie das gemacht
ich vergesse auch dass es immer noch
make-up einsteiger gibt auch in meinem
alter an wenn ihr mich nochmal renten
sehen wollt emp ganz ehrlich warum
verkauft ihr das sieben euro teurer das
möchte ich mal hören was dahintersteckt
hat euch den bringen konnten die ist das
bei conti die haben bei rossmann ihren
platz bekommen und ist doch alles gut so
rossmann will man ja auch make-up
adventskalender kaufen wer würde
ein adventskalender mit make up bei ihm
kaufen da will ich würde mal diese
verkaufszahlen so interessieren
auch bei dem letzten ich sage mal so ich
freue mich auf den nächsten
adventskalender weil der ist wirklich
mega cool und der hier war einfach ganz
ehrlich mir zwar schon mal gucken wie
das funktioniert in schwierigkeiten das
rot abzukriegen haben wir das 100 mich
nicht dass es meistens so ist wird auch
nicht gerade mein gesicht an das führt
sie jetzt auch nicht irgendwie auch das
mascara oder der kajal führt jetzt auch
nicht schlimm an aber in den komischen
beigeschmack ist dann läutet wir sind
beim nächsten mal wieder eure meinung
[Musik]